say it black lives matter it's okay we
do matter you don't matter any less to
me what racism looks like is calling to
see an apartment and turning on my phone
voice and showing up at set apartment
and getting excuses as to why it's no
longer correct in every cop car that
drives by me my blood pressure rises you
know there's an automatic you know fear
that grips me it looks like being told
generation after generation what it
means to survive in a black body when
you look at movies and TV shows and
whatever you still have the choice black
character or the choice brown character
whose head snapping or whatever that's
still a caricature of what blackness is
or isn't you know when you walk down the
street people afraid of you you know and
you get so used to it sometimes that you
even miss it
because it's just so much a part of life
I don't know if I'm gonna make it home
anytime a police officer goes by I'm
always having to look over my shoulder
it's that lack of safety I had a boss
once say well you know what girlfriend
that is not what I did on the weekend
you know and I kept thinking like do you
really talk to everybody like that is
that how I speak
I don't think that it's gotten better I
think that it's gotten more PC because
people don't want to be perceived as
racist they don't want to admit it and
they don't want to be called out on it
and they want to be able to sort of live
their lives and sort of get away with it
it messes with my ability to be able to
provide for my family you know a group
of white people might be sitting around
talking and they'll be talking about
black people in a very objectifying or
distancing kind of way that you know we
are talking about them and I don't think
that they necessarily realize that but
I'm included in that category we're
seeing resources pulled from our schools
and our school systems where our black
and brown kids are being educated
allowed to fail we're seeing more police
in our communities because we're thought
to be inherently criminal the idea that
it took so much to just get a
confederate flag down a sign of racist
you know intention and behavior if it
was that hard to take that flag down
imagine how hard it is so like eliminate
racism and racist ideologies our
children's deaths don't mean anything
you disrespect our elders you trample on
our traditions you love everything that
we produce but you don't love the people
who produce it you know I don't know I
don't know what else to do it's
important to really start calling things
what they are as long as things are
sugar-coated we're not going to be able
to address the actual problem saying I'm
not raised to saying I don't see raised
none of that really matters unless
you're actively trying to undo those
systems so what does that mean that
means utilizing your privilege to create
space for people of color to speak
songs in America black people have to
stop looking outward for approval and
getting on their knees and begging to be
accepted it's not gonna happen as long
as white people are privileged as long
as white supremacy exists and there is a
hierarchy on human life
none of us are free and black lives
don't matter so to end racism it's going
to take everyone is going to take all of
it but you have to like really look at
every single institution in this country
how does it manifest racism and you got
a chip away that we could start from
that place of recognizing my humanity
our humanity
the beauty of blackness the embracing of
blackness that might be some radical
change will require a radical look once
we're in that conversation instead of
the one that ignores it might be able to
move forward he's like yeah but what are
you gonna do and I'm going I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna be here forever